[Musica]
sono simona vengo dall'istituto tecnico
per il settore tecnologico di campobasso
e voglio raccontarvi una storia
cinque anni fa un gruppo di ragazzi
insieme ad alcuni docenti e alcuni
tecnici hanno deciso di costruire una
tastiera con delle mani che sono noto
nuovamente bene
da lì si è scatenato il putiferio ogni
anno altri ragazzi volevano creare
qualche altro strumento in modo da
riuscire a ricreare ciò che l'uomo fa
semplicemente seguendo una strada che
non esiste già una strada che non è già
abbattuta oggi vi parlerò di robot
guitar un progetto realizzato da per tre
anni da tre classi quindi da un triennio
completo un automa programmato per
suonare la chitarra appunto potrebbe
ledere la sensibilità dei puristi della
chitarra però in questo modo dove
andrebbero a finire invenzione talento
studio il punto è stato che non si
voleva sostituire completamente l'uomo o
insegnargli come fare musica l'obiettivo
principale era quello di creare una
nuova forma d'arte con le innovazioni
tecnologiche perché secondo voi cosa
hanno in comune software step motor
microcontrollori servomotori con la
musica
niente sembrano solo sterili congegni
però è l'idea che c'è dietro a renderli
speciali innovazione talento e studio
hanno fatto sì che si creasse la magia
l'obiettivo era quello di far suonare al
robot impararli a leggere la musica di
tutto il progetto si è svolto in tre
fasi principali la prima è stata come
costruire le dita
dopo un po di tentativi se arrivate a
crearne sei una per ogni corda e proprio
come le dita di un musicista attraverso
le quali passa l'energia che arrivata
sullo strumento diventa musica la stessa
energia passa attraverso le barre della
chitarra
la seconda fase è stata come far muovere
queste dita
qui entrano in gioco i famosi motori di
precisione
i servo motori e gli step motor loro
sono come i nervi i muscoli del nostro
corpo che bene esercitati danno il
giusto vigore e la giusta accuratezza
movimento
ora c'è la fase iii quella più difficile
come far muovere tutta la macchina
i ragazzi hanno scritto un software che
in grado di trasformare le note in
istruzioni da dare al robot per far
muovere le dita sui capotasti della
chitarra
in poche parole è stato insegnato al
robot a leggere gli spartiti
il successo di questo progetto è dato
dal fatto che si vuole volare un suono
meno meccanico più rotondo più armonioso
e ora vi faccio sentire quello che può
fare
lanciando il brano dall applicazione sul
telefono tramite bluetooth lancio i
segnali le istruzioni che che come
vengono trasformate dal software al
segnale della chitarra
[Musica]
c'è da dire che molti pezzi che
compongono questo automa non esistono
sul mercato perché sarò stadi prima
disegnati dai ragazzi e poi costruite ad
hoc per far sì che si integrassero alla
perfezione con il robot il talento di
ogni ragazzo è stato messo a
disposizione dell'altro perché hanno
lavorato in gruppo
il gruppo ha permesso di socializzare e
aiutarsi a riprendersi dove piccoli
fallimenti
il gruppo ha permesso di condividere non
sironi di ambiti diversi
il gruppo ha permesso di aggiustare ogni
volta il tiro
insomma sono stati uniti talento
invenzione studio per creare un automa
unico nel suo genere
vi faccio una domanda chi di voi non si
appassionerebbe davanti ad un oggetto
del genere
immaginate di poter lavorare in un
ambiente di ricerca concreto di poter
sviluppare soluzioni diverse di poter
gioire di fronte ai piccoli piccoli
piccole vittorie quotidiane
sicuramente non puoi mostrarsi come un
uomo però non hanno fatto i ragazzi
durante tutto il percorso che l'ha
portata alla realizzazione sicuramente
lo fanno ora quando la sentono suonare e
ripensano la passione che ci hanno messo
dietro
ora questo è quello che voi trovate se
venite nella mia scuola
questa è la realtà presente quest'anno
il gruppo di turno ha creato robot ram
la batteria che sono da sola e non
sappiamo se verrete fra dieci anni cosa
troverete se troverete il gruppo di
turno che sarà creando l'ennesimo
strumento da aggiungere alla tastiera
alla chitarra e alla batteria già
presenti ora non sappiamo come si
evolverà la robotica però nel film di
fantascienza fanno vedere che molte
volte i robot si ribellano ai propri
padroni
semmai questo dovesse succedere da noi
sicuramente lo faranno a suon di musica
[Applauso]